I'm going to find it very difficult to
vote for something myself because
there's something like this myself
because I believed that we should have
done
something different in the meantime I
will continue to campaign for for what I
thought of and what I think of as brexit
and the logic of brexit because this is
nothing if it is not a brexit government
and brexit is nothing if we in this
country don't do things differently
a lot of political correspondent Amanda
acass joins us live now from Westminster
a lot of people have been wondering what
Boris Johnson made of the negotiations
earlier in the week he's made it clear
he's not entirely comfortable with it
but does he have a great deal of
parliamentary support
well I think it's no surprise really to
most people in Westminster that Boris
Johnson disagrees with Rishi sunak's
whole conciliatory approach to the
problems with the Northern Ireland
protocol which of course Boris Johnson
agreed in order to get brexit done as he
put it by sitting down with the EU
reopening negotiations and ditching as
part of that Boris Johnson's signature
policy to deal with those problems which
was the Northern Ireland protocol bill
which effectively threatened to
unilaterally ditch the Northern Ireland
protocol and rip it up which was quite
clearly a threat to the EU and could
have led to a potential trade deal he
has kept us waiting since Monday to give
us his verdict and although he was
critical it wasn't the kind of
evisceration that some might perhaps
have expected I think he's probably
quite aware that he doesn't have a huge
amount of overt support from the back
benches on this many
um formerly strident brexiteers have
actually welcomed The Windsor framework
quite warmly as well there isn't the
kind of huge Brewing Rebellion that some
were kind of expecting Boris Johnson to
use as a vehicle to kind of storm back
to the leadership over all of this but
still the fact that he's saying he would
find it difficult to vote for it the
fact that he's urging where she soon act
to return to the Northern Ireland and
protocol Bill are problematic for him
because part of the negotiation with the
EU was the decision to drop the Northern
Ireland protocol bill because it was
felt that it was a threat by the EU so
clearly that's not something the Rishi
sunak is going to look to do and in this
speech today Boris Johnson also really
used it as an opportunity to really
defend brexit and sell the potential
opportunities of brexit he talked about
the importance of Divergence of doing
things differently and taking advantage
of it something which perhaps Mr sunac
himself hasn't been doing given that his
most recent high-profile comments were
about celebrating the opportunity he's
offered to Northern Ireland buys access
to the single Market as well as the UK